today i'm going to talk about reasoning
with natural language processing
uh and let me give you a quick
introduction about myself uh sanket has
done a great job
uh regarding that but let me give a
quick wrap-up about that so
i'm originally from saudi arabia i did
my bachelor degree in information
technology in one of the local
universities here in saudi arabia
and then i did my master's in computer
science in cornell university and then i
did another masters in university of
illinois urbana campaign and management
information system and then a phd at the
same university in the in the department
of um
informatics
after that i came back i joined as an
assistant professor here
at one of the local universities also um
in the information technology department
i moved after that to
oracle as a regional consultant for ai
data science and machine learning
it was really great uh doing all of this
as a journey i also have a startup
in ai and data science especially in
education uh training and uh
part of it is for raising awareness for
uh conducting uh content um
in in arabic language for enriching the
content in ai and data science
so for today's agenda we'll go through
four topics very quickly we have time
limitation as we know so i will try my
best as we as you know as as in academia
i tend to talk too much about the things
i like to work on
so today we're going to talk about what
is nlp
um
nlb applications of natural language
processing applications
and then arabic language um
analyzing arabic language and then some
resources that i
and tools and applications that i know
that are going to be useful and i have
seen their effect in analyzing and using
or
working with arabic language
so let's talk first about what is
natural language processing so this
presentation
uh as you all know is uh
is specified for everyone so
if anyone doesn't know what is arabic
what is natural language processing it's
one of the fields that i have started in
computer science and the idea of that
field of that domain is
understanding the interaction between
computers and humans so
and not just human in a in a in a very
big way but just their natural language
their language when they are speaking
when they are talking
how can computers understand that as we
know if we go a bit to that bigger
umbrella of ai artificial intelligence
the idea of ai since the 50s is
how can i make a machine
think and talk and
work as a human so how can i do that so
natural language processing is just
a tiny piece of ai where i how can i
make machines
interact
with human using language we will go
through that in a bit so
it's when we look at it it's the
interaction between human or the
language and computers so
how actually human talk they talk using
words in different languages of course
and but how computer actually actually
talk they talk with
zeros and ones so how can we
how can we convert words to zeros and
ones and zeros and ones to words so here
where it comes natural language
processing is how can i do that
conver conversation or that interaction
between both
and in natural language processing there
is two subfields
one of them is natural language
understanding
which is understanding
how computer can understand language and
then natural language generation is
where computer can generate
language so human can understand that
and if we give
an example is
the iphone with siri if we know about
that
um that's one of the examples
google
machine learning translation uh
translating language all of this is how
for example how the iphone is
talking to us and how when i when i
speak set my calendar
uh a meeting in my calendar at eight
uh tonight for example or whatever it's
gonna understand what i just said it's
gonna translate it to zeros and once and
then still do something in the machine
do that the command that i just said
and then
speak back that okay i have done that to
you
so when we talk about natural language
understanding what do we mean by that
uh similarly to cv amazon
alexa
it understands the input
the language and then converts them to a
structured
data inside the machine
it can it's it it does that by analyzing
this different aspects of the language
it does that by analyzing the language
by from different perspective etc
natural language generation is how
the machine
processes the structured data inside the
machine and
and transfer it into or translate it
into text
the text can be written or spoken etc
but the idea is how can i translate it
to a text in the beginning
so how can i process these meaningful
phrases and sentences
in the form of language natural language
for
for
other representations so that involves
how can i plan the text how can i plan
the sentence how can i plan the wordings
all of these so natural language
generation is also
it's a subdomain that concerned with how
can i translate
what the machine wants to say into
wordings into text sentences and
and most importantly to understand
so the human can understand the machine
very well
but going back to the big picture that i
referred to in the in the beginning how
nlp is related to
ai or artificial intelligence this is a
really great
picture of visualization that has
integrated how
artificial intelligence is related to
natural language as i put the box into
the field of natural language processing
under artificial intelligence there is
machine learning expert systems speech
vision robotics planning and other other
fields every day we we have seen how ai
is integrated with multiple applications
in multiple domains but when we focus on
natural language processing it's the sub
field that's concerned as we can see
here with text generation
answering questions classification
machine translation and we're going to
go through that very quickly
also if we are
looking at natural language processing
and how it's interacting with other
domains
beside computer science
it's
tightly integrated
with linguistic so ai is very really
when we we integrate ai with linguistic
we will get natural language processing
because
we need some
linguistic experience in understanding
textual data understanding how can i
interact with text data
and as we know
under the umbrella of ai there is
machine learning and deep learning
what are the applications well-known
applications natural language processing
i will go
through some of them
first is machine translation and
machine translation has been or
language translation by itself has been
in our culture since very very long
so
try having the machine doing the
translation is one of the great examples
of that
um
so when you
when you enter some wordings
and a very
very strong and very
powerful
machine that does that is google
translate it has been improved through
the use and we have seen that even in in
the very different
difficult languages specifically for
arabic for example it has been improved
very very widely in the past few years
translating languages from
one wording
to other
and especially capturing the context and
we're going to go through that as one of
the challenges actually another thing is
text summarization having a very huge
text
how can i extract the most important
keywords key phrases
and then creating a very summarized very
abstract
of the entire article
another example is named entity
recognition named entity recognition is
one of the
sub uh domains of natural language
processing is how can i use
or understand or extract
the entities out of the world things
that we have for example
elon musk as a person facebook as an
organization do i mean today is a date
how can i understand the person between
for example apple the organization and
apple the the fruit
this is a great also um summary of
the language technologies that in
natural language processing has been
solved they are making good progress all
they are still
um really hard to understand
um or it's still really hard to ch very
challenging to work with
mostly solved are
example spam detection part speech
tagging and named entity recognition
uh the things that are still really hard
of question answering how to make the
machine when i ask
a question is going to reply and then
i'm going to give another question it's
going to reply etc
which is part of being having a dialogue
with the machine we are still not not
there yet we there's a lot of work that
needs to be done there and there's other
examples
so difficulties ambiguity language is
very ambiguous that's why we have a lot
of difficulties in natural language
processing
and there's different levels of
ambiguity if we go there
um one of them is lexical ambiguity for
example the word word is it noun or
another ambiguity level is syntax level
ambiguity um
how can i
resolve that another difficulties with
working with language is
referential if i am referring to someone
in my speech how the machine can
understand which person i'm referring to
and there is other other
difficulties
related to homographs for example beer
is it the verb of the noun how can i
make differences between those
apple is it the company or the fruit
of noisy data spelling mistakes etc
when thinking about these difficulties
how can i
imagine them in any different language
these difficulties have actually arise
in english language how they arise in
arabic language as we know our clan
which is one one of the
uh one of the languages that i'm spoken
by more than
360 million persons around the world
around the world so how can we
understand these difficulties why it's
hard to
use natural language processing in
arabic language
first of all there is a lot of forms of
arabic language
we have the classical arabic which is
used for textual data
of classical historical data or text
modern standard arabic which is used in
news media and formal languages and then
the delicate arabic which is
what we used in what we use in our daily
life when we talk with people in
different uh
in our region and actually delicate out
because is is we have multiple
uh delicates all around
our regions and people who speak arabic
they have different delicates sometimes
me from saudi arabia i will not be able
to understand all right i have
difficulties understanding language
so why arabic language is hard i'm going
to give some examples or some issues
that beside what we have in other
languages
the ambiguity that is arised there
also
there is specific
challenges in arabic language itself
first
complex word structure in arabic it's
very complex
to there was a lot of wordings that are
very complex as a structure this is one
example uh i have in the beginning the
arab report as we can see here we have
the prefix
the stem the suffix
there is a lot of wordings inside
um that makes the the
the wordings and and how can we
take the word itself so it is to its
suit very difficult to be done as we
know working with language uh the
easiest way is to take or the best way
to deal with with textual data is you
take the stem the the
uh you take the word to its root so you
are able to understand what is what is
this word is about but taking it to the
root sometimes it's an arabic language
is not that easy to do by itself
other thing is the problem of
normalization
the this is the letter a the first
letter in arabic letter alif
this is the whole um
um
structure of the this is the different
ways of writing the letter
and there's other ways of fighting other
wordings also so that's one of the
problems is how can i normalize like
that letter how can i normalize
each letter in arabic especially with
different word names and that comes with
the arabic script when i write arabic
there is different ways of writing
we have even different type of different
ways of writing arabic
as we can see here all of these three
uh sentences
are saying the same word
but the problem is i'm writing it in
different
ways and actually because here it's in
in a in a computer sometimes if i'm
trying for example
a complicated uh situation when i have a
handwriting
when you when we write arabic we have
different ways of writing um some of
them are very artistic
so how can i
extract the wording out of a handwriting
that's a really difficult challenge for
arabic so all of these three letters
three wordings i have the letter as we
can see here in different uh structures
of different writing uh with with other
ways of writing uh of writing the letter
itself
another issue is morphology morphology
also when i when i have a word
um
even
even if i wrote that word in in its root
for example all of these
letters of all of these sentences are
words have this root
so
how can i know if
this word actually means
how can i extract that meaning because
when i take it to the root i want to
have the meaning extracted but for
example this word is this word is kataba
which is
he wrote something but when i all of
this wording this is
for example kitab this is a book
so
when i take the root of a book it means
writing so
when when i take everything to its
throat it's not the right way of doing
it i'm
um there's a problem with with
understanding the language even this is
mataba which is library if i take the
root of library it's going to be
writing he wrote something or writing so
it's it's uh there is there is
there is the the problem of morphology
we're when i take the wording to its
root
i'm losing the meaning of the word
itself so that's another challenge that
need to be
investigated or need to be worked with
and many others
to to summarize also these is um
writing arabic numbers
uh of wordings i write from left to
right
um versus um
in english is right to left so uh sorry
it's the way
it's it's uh all the way around in
arabic we write from right to left in
english we write from left to right so
that's another another issue so with the
writing even writing is is from
different in in different ways even the
numbers we write them
from the way around also different than
the english language another thing is
the feminine marker
um
uh in in arabic
that we have a feminist marker when i
talk about
uh or when you describe an object for
example big
and
big describes
uh both uh male and female for example
big book for example in arabic is
different i have a feminist markup
it's a feminine for example
object
[Music]
that's another issue that how to
differentiate between objects that are
have feminine markers
and it doesn't another issue is proper
name spelling
when i when i differentiate
um um for example uh
schwarzenegger
that's a one word written in english if
i translate that
into arabic or i try it try to write it
in arabic wording i'm gonna have
more than four
actually than the one that i've written
i'm gonna write it in a very different
way if i give that work to 100 people
i'm gonna have one hundred different way
of writing just that one
especially also um the wording of
different uh objects uh some people have
um
for example tomato in arabic people say
that say that word in different
diff using different wordings uh either
adding
one more
letter or removing one more letter or
even changing the name
in a different and all of them are
speaking arabic actually
lastly is
recognizing arabic versus other
languages that are using the same arabic
letter so there is for example persian
or or of the these are actually other
languages
but they are using the same letters that
we are using in arabic so how can i
differentiate between that this wording
so
that's all also
another issue that we have here uh we
have while dealing with arabic language
is recognizing arabic from different
languages
so so to sum up um
uh or to give a to give a
uh hope
um
these are some resources that the
the
researchers and brilliant people have
worked with many tools to try to
understand arabic language and try to
help with
understanding or analyzing and
introducing many many solutions to these
to these challenges that i just talked
about
besides there was many other challenges
that we have to work with anyway but
these are one of them
uh some of the tools that have available
online um easy to use um
libraries
python libraries
birth using birth technologies um
using
[Music]
all of them actually available in github
and
very easy to find and allocate to
be able to analyze and
understand textual uh language uh or
specifically our textual language either
analyzing them
doing
summarization tokenization part speech
tagging
all of the
natural language processing techniques
that need to be done
so
with that i end my presentation thank
you so much for your
time and listening there is maybe one or
two minutes for answering questions if
there is any if anybody have any
question
in the q a or in the chat we'll be happy
to answer them
thank you so much
um thank you aseal uh that was a great
presentation uh
so i think we have our first question uh
uh the question goes from luis it's like
do you train embeddings and do you use
any tricks there
okay so uh yes of course using
embeddings of uh
in in
in natural language processing is one of
the well-known applications for for
understanding language and trying to
um
trying to build models regarding for
example for text generation optics
understanding
um
so
one of the one of the
one of the things i have worked with
before is trying to understand
uh uh trying to extract actually the
the the root of the words and trying to
to to know how what is the best way of
extracting
um
transferring them into embeddings and
using that for for
uh for
for text generation or
text understanding and there was another
question i also have seen here related
which do you have any specific arabic
trained burped in hugging face um
for myself i don't but i have seen a lot
of
a lot of uh trained arabic specific
trained births in in hugging phase and
you can share some of them and uh
in stock channel that
after after the talk
oh thank you uh so just just so just to
give attention to everyone that uh we
have slack channels for all the talks
and workshops like every workshop has a
dedicated slack channel but we don't
have a dedicated slack channel for talks
but if you like to like if the speaker
wants to have a dedicated talk channel
we can create one uh or you could just
go in the talks uh slack channel and ask
a question over there
uh so there's another question uh by
guilio which goes like very interesting
and exciting excellent delivery uh any
public data set you would like you would
recommend exploring
i sorry can you
say that plane yeah uh they are asking
any public data set you would recommend
exploring
yeah i'm sure they're referring to the
arabic data center yes so uh
on top of my mind i
there is a lot of data in in
for our especially social media data so
if you want it very challenging
arabic textual data social media is is
the best because people there are
are writing um arabic in
and using
[Music]
a lot of uh
there's a lot of spelling mistakes
there's a lot of normalization to be
done there's a lot of understanding of
human
uh
uh speech there
easier arabic language textual data is
going to use articles using google api
or
google news api etc
or
another example is using for example uh
books sexual books or
i have seen a great example using arabic
language with with poetry arabic poetry
uh that's also another uh great training
data to to to play with uh but for me i
really like um
i really like social media because um
part of my work is understanding
psychology or behaviors understanding
human behaviors while using why while
right through the language that they are
writing
awesome uh so we're gonna take one last
question uh which is by suri
which is how do you how do you handle
speaker diarization
so you understand my question right yeah
clear right now sorry
um
the
when when dealing with dialogue
anyway um
one of the first techniques that we have
started
we i have seen
uh
people using is when you have a
full stop that's the sentence
that's the end of using explanation mark
or
question that's the end of uh so the one
of the ways when we're using that with a
dialogue
is
understanding where the context is
stopped one of the easiest way is having
question mark when i have a question
mark that means i'm waiting for a
response
but the problem is with when when
i don't know when um i i can separate it
when i don't know if there is no
question for example
uh when does
that person have stopped and he's
waiting for an answer i think
what i what i have seen now from from
all of the studies or the research has
gone with is um
is using
um
punctuations using especially if it's
written text punctuation is always the
right way for always do it the best way
or the easiest way to separate
uh
the dialogue beside that um
i'm not i'm i don't i don't have
knowledge more than than than that
uh for regarding where how to understand
where the dialogue will stop
uh i think we will need someone who is
an expert in direct understanding or
have worked with dialogues uh to be able
to answer such questions but from
what i have stopped that's i think
that's the easiest way is to see where
this uh
where is the usage of punctuations and
especially in writing
i'm pretty sure there are there are many
qualified data scientists or
professionals in the whole attendee
attendees list you know for the globe
yeah if someone has a better answer i'm
happier i
also would like to learn but as i said
natural language processing in is a very
big field and
uh
there is a lot of experts who
we and
here we are here to learn from each
other so
awesome thank you uh so uh thank you for
the presentation it was it was pleasure
to have you and i really enjoyed it so
that brings us end of the presentation
for this one
you